in this is the first time the
continent's leaders have met to discuss
the
challenges and the opportunities of
climate change is right here the
restoration and expansion of Africa's
natural carbon sinks are
just are not just an environmental
imperative in
fact they are an unpar parallel economic
gold
mine they have the potential to absorb
millions of tons of CO2 annually which
should translate into billions of
dollars if we living in a fair World
Excellency some delegates say they want
African head of state to put more
pressure on Rich Nations to help less
wealthy countries deal with climate
change others say Africa can be
self-reliant I think the narrative is
changing very rapidly in the sense that
Africa used to play victim to the impact
of climate change but more and more
we're beginning to see that there are
actually benefit that we need to
capitalize on nage as
Africa delegates here are also talking
about climate and conflict some
countries are facing serious security
challenges back home and that makes it
very difficult to deal with climate
change
effects droughts in the Horn of Africa
have become more severe and conflict
over resources intense other countries
in Central and West Africa are also
facing
upheaval Gabor a global leader in
conservation is the latest country to
face political uncertainty after the
Army overthrew president Ali Bongo the
Au has suspended the country over the
coup we're not saying there's a direct
link between conflict and climate change
what we're saying saying is that it
exacerbates or amplifies pre-existing
conflicts and tensions at the close of
the summit the heads of state are
expected to agree on a common position
that can represent the continent at the
UN climate change conference in
November Katherine soy Al jaaz Nairobi
Kenya make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer